live from the headquarters of Ramsey
solutions
it's the Dave Ramsey show we're glad
you're here
thanks for being with us in the lobby
right here with us is Frank and Denise
hey guys how are you great hey Dave
welcome where you all from we're from
Austin Texas very cool here to do your
debt-free scream that's it I love it how
much have you paid off
we paid off eighty-three thousand
dollars in debt and we managed to
cashflow another $25,000 because Murphy
took up residence in the spare bedroom
no what was that for my surgery a cat
surgery the list goes on fence repairs
Denise broke the faucet you know Denise
broke the faucet I watched her do it
after the cat and you the faucets
nothing no no there was nothing
Denise broke the faucet that's what's
gonna happen to your head if you keep
this up it's not gonna be good for you
how long did it take you to pay off
eighty three thousand dollars then
twelve months Wow what's your range of
income during that time we are just
north to 200,000 whoa good what do you
guys do for a living I'm a software
developer and I'm the vice president of
Human Resources for amplify credit union
very cool good for you guys actually
both work for the same credit union okay
great great careers then though oh that
yeah excellent very cool so what turned
all this home 12 months ago so it's real
interesting we started listen we've been
listening to the Bobby bones show and
they had just moved to Nashville and we
were kind of upset about that and then
we heard them interview this great guy
who was gonna be a guest on the show
Dave Ramsey we hadn't heard of you
before
and so we listened through that
interview and heard you talking about
stupid tax and you know trying to earn
your earn your way out of debt or you
know earn your stupidity for debt and we
just really said we got to go by this
guy's book today so we went online we
ordered your book and then over the next
week Frank and I read the
to each other in about five days just
kind of alternated chapters and stayed
up late and got it done and after that
we ordered the financial piece CDs
listen to all the CDs straight through
and said this is it this is going to
change our lives and so we're ready to
get on a plan and then Murphy just
continued to hit our lives over and over
again it Frank was diagnosed with kidney
cancer whoa right when we were getting
ready to do our first budget Wow so that
was the first thing and thank God he's
he's got a big eight inch scar under
there if anybody wants to see it later
he's not proud of it but he is he is
doing great and so but between that and
a family member who came to us asking to
help them with a loan for a substantial
amount of money we kind of looked at
their situation and could see ourselves
in that these were people that look like
they had everything they did have
everything they had the cars the jewelry
the house that gave you the wake-up call
it did it was the you know we're sick
and tired of being sick and tired moment
and we could see ourselves looking like
that but not being like that in the
future and so we hit pause on our
snowball before we even started and we
piled up cash so that we could cash flow
Frank's surgery deductible coinsurance
his being out of work for six weeks to
get well and basically paying for
surgeries and paying off this debt in 12
months is all you've done I mean you've
been on beans and rice rice and beans to
do that I'm 200k you knocked this out
back pretty much we really I love your
gazelles in the lobby that I'm seeing on
the on the glass and and Frank had to
laugh when we came in because he always
what did you say honey well Denise likes
to be gizelle in tents but I'm more
meerkat in tents I kind of shut my head
I keep poking my head up looking around
for predators but I'm not running for my
life yet but we did we really changed
changed our life and and our parents all
of our parents are great role models we
have my parents here Debbie and Hank
Pearson and they've just been huge
supporters of every step of the way
I mean you cut this budget to the bone
you've been living on we're any of your
friends making fun of it you know it's
funny since we work for a credit union
and I really appreciate that you always
give credit unions I'm kind of an odd
for taking care of people in the way you
take care of folks here we love reading
and so a little bit you know when I'm
pulling cash out of my envelope you know
at lunch some of our executives you know
this a little bit of the eye roll and
you know that kind of thing and we do
have a few people that are really proud
of their 800 credit score and when I
tell him it cost him a hundred thousand
dollars in interest they don't like that
so much but for the most part we just
were met with a lot of success and
support Wow
very very cool so what kind of debt was
the eighty-three thousand let's see it
was credit cards and here shaking a box
of shredded credit cards that's all full
of shredded credit cards about 45 of
them oh my gosh
yeah we kept trying to transfer balances
and one of the pictures we sent Kelly
has them all splayed out on the table
and some of them have the stickers they
were never even activated but we just
couldn't whatever interaction and that's
that's the remains of 45 credit cards
yes sir yeah how much of the 83,000 was
credit card debt most of it really yeah
and by the way we super glued this shut
so that we can't piece them back
together right as if you would be
tempted after all you guys have been
through we also closed
we also had an air conditioning unit at
the last minute and we had about $18,000
in a vehicle Wow Wow just boom boom boom
boom just like that so how does it feel
now that you've taken control of your
life instead of those stinking cards
controlling you
it's a lot better yeah I thought the
budget was going to be the hard part and
that it was going to be it was just
gonna restrict my life but it was just
the opposite doing the budget the first
couple of times was hard because it took
a little while to get used to it but
once we got the budget down then I
understood that really was giving us
that you know the permission to spend in
those categories as we had allocated and
so it really it was a better thing it's
a lot better now we still do it we're
gonna continue to do it you know the
weird thing is if you agree on it
budget actually frees you up other than
constriction absolutely I think what's
weird
and we've actually we have four
college-age children right now freshman
sophomore junior and senior and we have
shared with them the value of budgeting
and even though they don't have a lot of
expenses right now and they don't have a
lot of money coming in it's starting to
change their lives and just being really
transparent with our kids and saying you
know we we didn't do it right in the
first half of our life and we're gonna
finish better than we started very cool
very proud of you guys congratulations
you're heroes can I give you guys a
shout out for your team Dave real quick
so being in human resources one of the
greatest things that we've done is
myself and Frank of course just keeping
a financial wellness program going for
ourselves so we call ourselves disciples
of Dave we've we listened to your
podcast every day three hours a day
every day it's just our dose and we also
brought the smart dollar program to our
credit unions and since I am responsible
for the budget in my department I get to
do those things and got really great
support from our executive team to do it
and your team everybody here that I've
worked with dryden Nielsen is our sales
is our Account Manager she's amazing
Kristy Albers and Pat McGarry and the
sales on this came out to Austin met
with me personally and are really
working with me to try to get this into
our credit union industry and then also
Kevin Thomas and I have just started
working together to see if we can put
something together around the middle
school and high school program where our
credit union conduced some community
good with supporting those kind of
things and you do the best hiring Dave I
cannot tell you we have to say we do cuz
I don't do any of it but here to try to
help you but our team our team does a
great job of screening and we've got
some absolutely incredible thoroughbreds
on the team we are really really much
are you really proud we are thank you
for giving us a shout out we appreciate
that alright Franken denise austin texas
83,000 plus 25 and denise broke the
faucet in 12 months make a 200
and count it down let's hear a debt-free
scream 3 2 1
well done you two
well done that's how you do it right
there folks a hand very fun very fun you
just don't get this kind of stuff on
other shows this is the Dave Ramsey show
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show and so you have to break the
cycle you have to flip this thing on its
head and make it behave you've got to
get so fired up and wired up that you're
broke friends think you've lost your
mind